[Music]
my favorite memory wow that is amazing
my favorite memory would have to be Wow
I don't really know um honestly right
now I'm making them this is the first
time that I really left a state on a
vacation and like this is like most
beautiful thing I've ever seen like I
think I'm gonna remember this for the
rest of my life I haven't really seen
anything or done anything like this
Thanksgiving the family so when there to
be harmony in on the dinner table and
before everybody grew up and became
their own individuals and stuff so I
just went through Marine Corps training
I graduated today so my favorite
memories in his day was
is climbing the infamous Reaper it's a
giant mountain that we have Camp
Pendleton and just getting to the top
and getting an Eagle Globe and Anchor
and earning the title those it's
probably my favorite moment this day my
honeymoon sitting on my dad's lap when
he was smoking a pipe and just feeling
very comfortable with him and very happy
that smell of the pipe just makes me
think of him
well we're just think make you feel and
I've never seen anything like that it
was a big cake
I'm here with my friend from England
that I haven't seen her for 10 years
and it's actually amazing I might have
made it today
[Music]
there's baby feel better okay screams
I'm married just amazing like a little
baby in Trinidad where I grew up and
going to the beach and kayaking to this
little remote area and then coming back
and in the dark and my parents be here
probably finishing the community
last year in Spain it's a 500-mile hike
across the north of Spain from the east
to the west coast
it's like an old pilgrimage people used
to where people have been doing for
just a solo hike into the woods for like
six weeks my favorite memory is
definitely like me and my brother out in
the bay about couples go and we're just
out in the ocean and the waves are just
coming in and it's just a great
beautiful time well yesterday my wife
and I actually had our four-year
anniversary and we're celebrating it
here in San Diego so I have to say my
favorite memory was four years and one
day ago when I got to say I do to the
most beautiful woman on the planet
my favorite memory was when I used to go
to the mosque with my mom
in my eye and after the service we would
like have a huge meal we'll all eat
together
those are like some of my favorite
probably there was a couple summers ago
that my boyfriend and I were
just kind of at a downtown street
festival and just grew up on top of the
merry-go-round
or the Pharisee just like looking at
everything and just you could see the
whole city and it's just everybody
having a good time
there's just a beautiful scene of like
our hometown
my favorite memory would have to be the
first time that I went back home to
Kurdistan and it was my first time
eating breakfast outside sitting outside
picnic style and my grand friends front
yard I think
my my 50th birthday week I spent a week
in Colorado and it was probably the best
week of my life just outside in the
mountains hiking and running and yeah it
was gorgeous well I think for now is
traveling with my friends to San Diego
my favorite memory has to be when I was
camping and I was discovering just being
in nature and being by myself seeing who
I was as a person being alone time is
the best time just my favorite memory it
was dancing salsa
a friend of mine
and he didn't know how to dance salsa so
I was teaching now
I had his arms on my hips and we were
doing the counts and dancing
later he ended up dying
so
that's my favorite
just a moment of purity between two
people having this experience and when I
think of him that's what I remember
my favorite memory is waking up on my
ranch in Mexico and going horseback
riding with my uncle and my little
cousin while the Sun is rising the day
each of my children were born
celebrating the new year in Chinese
culture
my father got seven brothers and sisters
so around thirty people gathering
together and to celebrate this great
festival my favorite memory is when my
oldest brother inky got engaged to my
sister-in-law with my mom and she liked
to plant a lot of different kinds of
plants in their backyard so I was my
favorite memory when I was growing up
and I go visit my grandparents that
lived in northern Utah and I remember
going there in the summer and they would
wake me up early with a homemade
breakfast and just take care of me and
it was some of the happiest days of my
life I would have to say my favorite
memory is when I met my wife
when I married my wife though she's
right here say it was when I was
learning how to fit we had my dad gave
me a fishing rod he tied like a piece of
metal to it like to the end of the line
and then I would just swing it back and
forth because I owned a factory so now
we'll get it caught on like stuff
it was the hiking through the Mukesh
Kadal in the Negev desert was actually
just here it was awesome swimming with
the sea lions I guess it would have to
be the last time I saw my grandma we all
went up to our house and her house in LA
and that's the last time our whole
family
it was a blind date and I showed up with
a five pack of beer because I drank one
in the carwash going over because I was
so scared and he asked me that night
after our date
if because it was leap year if I decided
I wanted to marry him to give him a call
and we've been married 37 years
[Music]
you